m
[Musique]
le salon de l'agriculture de paris qui
attend 620 mille visiteurs sur la
semaine a ouvert ses portes ce samedi 24
février dans le pavillon 5 les régions
d'outre-mer dont l'île de la réunion qui
dévoile son village de 600 mètres carrés
on fait beaucoup dégustation fait bien
connaître nos produits et les gens ils
sont un peu étonnés quand je dis de
bananes
il associe tout de suite à la guadeloupe
martinique et quand je dis la réunion
bas à la réunion aussi des bananes
oui ben c'est très bien c'est les jeunes
apprécient déguste bien ils posent
beaucoup de questions on a quand même
pas mal de rayonner qui viennent alors
ça fait deux accès ouvert et pas mal de
monde déjà des créoles un peu de tout le
monde et surtout des gens qui sont très
curieux et qui achètent le prenais très
content s'est il fait chaud à
l'intérieur et les gens sont très
contents des produits du rhum des
bouchons des achards de la vanille du
cari de fruits rien ne manque sur le
village dans les années des
métropolitains enquête exotisme et des
réunions vont se ressourcer obligé par
le choix rapport découvrir les produits
et nouveautés
réapprendre détruit comme pascal plein
de trucs que je me rappelais plus tout
le temps c'est soit martinique réunion
et tout ça parce que j'aime bien
justement il ya l'europe bien sûr vous
avez aussi la nourriture et des gâteaux
et ou quoi l'an dernier nous avons passé
trois mois à la réunion nous étions à la
saline les bains et nous avons découvert
l'île avec un bonheur ça a été vraiment
que ce soit les fruits que ce soit les
légumes que ce soit les marchés que ce
soit les gens j'ai fait des découvertes
et des rencontres exceptionnelles vingt
exposants réunionnais participe
actuellement à ce salon de l'agriculture
devenu un rendez vous incontournable
[Musique]